okay last week we had a very special
vegan dessert tasting because it was
vegan producer Pat's birthday and as a
result it really seems to have triggered
in the best way not triggered in a
negative way but triggered in the best
way a deluge of mostly positive and of
course some negative comments about
producer Pat but their negative
there's always negative comments about
anything we do however one of Pat's
biggest admirers has left a voicemail at
two one nine to david p i don't know
that i could sum up call her Bobby's
feelings other than to say he is quite
taken with Pat take a listen to this I
thought your highest secured most famous
gay for gay fan Bobby I'm so sorry that
I missed your birthday I wish I could I
wish you participated birthday with me I
love you more than any other gay guy in
the whole world
Oh Patrick you're so beautiful you were
the father Phyllis sexiest young to do
that ever seen in my life happy birthday
Patrick I love you I want to marry you
so I am NOT going to reject the
assertion from this caller that they are
your your biggest gay fan but I don't
think that they're your biggest
heterosexual fan because there are other
people who call in or write in and they
say I am heterosexual but I
I love Pat and it had super attractive
so I think that will take Bobby at his
word that he's your biggest gay fan
because no one else is sort of like
self-appointed themselves but I think
that there is definitely there are
definitely bigger heterosexual fans of
Pat Forde I just don't know if I can
marry this caller you know I don't think
I can Gary someone who for you don't
even know they you don't even know okay
so anyway people very very excited about
Pat's birthday and it was an incredible
birthday weekend I'm sure and people
loving it people loving it so that's
that congratulations to Pat and I don't
know for what I mean he congratulate 23
years that's what we accomplished made
alive for an additional year and we're
all grateful for that on the bonus show
today it's hard to transition out of
that and I struggled but I think I've
transitioned out on the bonus show half
of America is in
Burtie I'll explain what I mean by that
Kellyanne Conway is saying that some of
the criticism of her is gender based an
interesting argument for Kellyanne
Conway to make and also the Air Force
wants permission to shoot down civilian
drones what is that all about why do
they want that right and is it a good
idea all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show you can sign up and
get instant access to the bonus show
it's a whole other show if you like this
show why not get the bonus show it's
more show you can sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership coupon code
is I voted seventeen and remember
pledges of as little as a dollar a month
where can you do on patreon.com slash
David Pakman show we will speak to you
on the bonus show